hi everyone so
today i'm going to present you the uh
general overview of
uh microfluidic technology developed at
luna 4
and the auto stainer lab set
we're gonna go through a specific
application of lab set which is the
automated tsa based multiplexing and
and see how to optimize the an essay on
tonsil tissue
and then we're going to see a method for
easy transferred of those optimized
protocol to cancer tissues and in a
specific case study on non-sponsored
lung carcinoma
so um luna 4 core technology is based on
a microfluidic chip
called mtp for microfluidic tissue
processor
it is used for tissue analysis assays
like immunofluorescence or
immunohistochemistry
the chip is equipped with a series of
microfluidic
channels used for reagent delivery
it is clamped against a standard glass
slide
that makes a closed chamber over the
tissue sample
this technology is called a fast footing
exchange
for ffx
so the pressure driven reagent flows uh
directly almost instantaneously in the
chamber
the liquid exchange is very rapid
between the steps
a heating element placed just below the
slide
allows precise temperature control at
any time as well as
rapid temperature changes the perfect
ceiling between the chip
and the in the slide offers a controlled
environment
to the tissue with multiple benefits
staining times are much faster due to
reduced
diffusion times in the chamber
there is a more uniform staining over
the tissue
and the rapid and high temperature
epitope retrieval are made possible
while preventing region evaporation and
preserving the tissue
this technology was born at the swiss
federal institute
of technology in lausanne and the
efficiency of the ffx
method in the ihe techniques was first
shown
on her two stainings of breast carcinoma
where it was
helping reducing significantly the two
plus
borderline scorings that are considered
as
ambiguous readouts in immunofluorescence
the mtp-based assays were also shown to
correlate
with the number of her2 gene copy
numbers
the mtp chip is integrated
in an automated device that is called
labset research
regions are simply loaded in
eight standard eppendorf and buffers are
stored in
four falcon tubes the chip
is placed in a staining chamber
maintained by a lid
ready to be clamped against a slide
another important microfluidic element
of the system
is the distribution ship it acts as a
gateway between the reservoirs
and the chamber and ensures the proper
control of the flow
towards the tissue reagents
are pushed from the reservoir towards
the distribution system
from where their dispense is controlled
to the staining chamber once the region
is finished
reagents are simply discarded to a
liquid waste
after having tested and proven the
efficiency of the
mtp on single markers immunofluorescence
and hypnosisochemistry we decided to
move towards
multiplexing assays there is an
important drive towards multiplexing
techniques
as the context of personalized medicine
requires even higher number
of markers to be investigated in order
to build better diagnostics
multiplexing immunofluorescence and
immunohistochemistry in particular
are interesting as they allow for
simultaneous marker detection
while keeping the information of
morphological context
that is especially relevant in the study
of the interaction between the tumor and
its micro
environment so the method
chosen uh to do immuno for instance
multiplexing on lab set
is the tyramid signal amplification tsa
this technique allows simultaneous
marker detection on the same tissue
the working principle is the following
so on
your first antigen of interest you would
detect using a primary antibody that you
would bind
with a secondary antibody conjugated to
an enzyme
here a horseradish peroxidase that in
turn
will catalyze the reaction of a tyramid
for a conjugate that binds to the
tuberosine residues
at the antigen site before moving
to the next marker detection the
antibodies need to be removed
by application of heat on the tissue
this step
is called elusion the covalent bound
between the rosin and the teramide
ensures that the signal
stays on the tissue even after the
elusion step
then next subsequent markers can be
detected using the same method
but and just by applying a different
flow form
this can be repeated for all the markers
in
a panel and once
all the termites are bound the slide is
ready for imaging
the tsa kit chosen for this project is
the widely used
opel kit from aquaria biosciences and
the goal was to adapt
these reagents to the lab set system
we use the seven color manual detection
uh
for six markers plus uh conscious
staining
uh with floor fours uh of excitation
wavelengths
ranging from 520 to 690 nanometers
so our objective is to um
automatize a full six plex using the
opel kit and um while the
pre-processing meaning the perfect
departurization
rehydration of the tissue as well as
imaging
will still be done outside a lab set
the machine will take on all the steps
that are directly
related to the staining itself starting
with the heat induced epitope retrieval
uh pruning blocking primary antibody
secondary antibody
and the tsa itself then elusion
all those steps being repeated in the
number of times corresponding to the
detected markers and finally country
staining
the sa development process was organized
around four main axes
the first one the singleplex
optimization
for each marker with the objective to
reach
good and repeatable performance for
every marker individually
the second axis is the uniformity
optimization
with the aim to obtain homogeneous
signal levels over the tissue
even over large sections and then the
antibody elusion optimization
to make the heat induced strip off
reach complete antibody removal between
cycles
while preserving the tissue morphology
at the same time
and finally the multiplexing part
bringing all the
individual optimized elements in one
multiplexing assay
and build a fast and efficient workflow
on the machine
the six markers selected for the panel
are typical immunomarkers foxp3 pdm1 pd1
cd68 cd8
plus pan ck for cytokeratins
the optimization of the assay was done
on ffpe
sections of human tonsils a positive
control tissue for those markers
so first axis of the tonsil optimization
project
singleplex optimization
so the sa was directly developed on lab
set
with the goal to ensure high staining
quality
while keeping a reduced execution time
the parameters could be directly
adjusted from the software interface of
labs that research and
the parameters that were available
for us to to play with were the
antigen retrieval so both temperature
and pressure settings
the regent incubation here again
temperature duration
and region flow optimization and finally
primary antibody and substrate titration
just like
in any regular assay the image
acquisition was done on
a mantra imaging station and the inform
software
was used for image analysis
when using the opel detection system
acquisitions need to be
process in particular the signal signal
needs to be deconvoluted
to separate the information compare
corresponding to each opel flow for
we built a spectral library prior to
this study and used
inform to do unmixing as well as cell
segmentation of the tissue for further
analysis and quantification
the single back staining optimization
resulted in bright and
specific signal for all the markers with
high normalized mean intensity
of balance value across the six markers
the results are here displayed in
software reconstructed bright field view
which is the
inform pathology view
for each marker the variability of the
protocol was assessed
on nine consecutive slides the single
plex repeat wdt
showed less than 15 percent of the
signal of signal variability
underlining the effective automation of
vocals on that system
now the uniformity axis uniformity of
the fluorescent signal is an important
feature
of an optimized protocol that can be
challenging
to obtain some time especially on large
tissue sections
labsat offers some interesting
functionalities
that help obtaining a better uniformity
when using a standard incubation of the
reagent on the tissue
depending on the method that is applied
this can lead to an
inhomogeneity in the signal level across
your tissue
labset allows for an active control of
the flow during the incubation
the liquid motion in the chamber can be
controlled at any time
ensuring a more uniform distribution of
the reagent over the tissue
this method called dynamic incubation
increased significantly the level of
uniformity
of stainings done on lab set
we assessed the efficiency of dynamic
incubation
by looking at the signal gradient on
slides incubated in a standard fashion
versus
the slides that we're applying the
dynamic incubation method and
we saw that over one centimeter of
tissue the signal drop
was reduced down to six percent uh when
using dynamic incubation
compared to 30 percent with a standard
incubation
which represents a significant
improvement in uniformity
the third axis of the project is the
elusion optimization
the role of the elusion step is to
ensure a proper removal of
the primary secondary antibody complex
between
two marker detections the method that we
use on labsad
is simply applying a high
heat to the tissue to assess
the efficiency of this evolution method
we compared a reference
stain slide versus an eluted slide
which simply consists in applying the
illusion process
after primary antibody and secondary
antibody
incubations before re-incubating with
secondary antibody
and the substrate if the illusion is
efficient
no signal should be observed on the
eluted slide
the illusion efficiency was defined as
the signal removal rate
the solution efficiency was tested for
all the markers in the panel
and signal removal rate was over 99
percent
for all the six of them which was
considered
as a performant illusion
since our illusion process involves high
temperature
it was important to test
that the repetition of those each cycles
would have limited impact on tissue
morphology
so we tested uh different repetition
numbers of those heating cycles
for three different uh singleplex
and we could observe no apparent
degradation uh
of the the resulting staining
due to the repetition of the illusion
nuclear morphology
extracellular metrics and epitope
detections
were preserved
the last part of this tonsil
optimization
it's the full six plexus say and
our goal is to build an efficient
workflow with a
minimum number of user interactions
so the tissue preprocessing and region
preparation is handled by the user
then then that then has to load all the
elements
on the machine lab set then perform
fully automatically free marker
detections
then due to limited number of reservoirs
a user intervention is required made
protocol
in order to load the regions needed for
the last
three cycles after what the protocol can
be resumed
and finished finally the slide can be
retrieved at the end of the protocol
mounted and imaged
the final result is a semi-automated
sixplex plus counter staining
that can be achieved in four hours and
12 minutes
the full essay showed adequate marker
detection compared to the single plex
optimization
the conclusion of this first part of the
study
is that the labs that offers a tsa based
multiplexing approach with high signal
intensity for each marker
an adequate signal uniformity across the
tissue section
an efficient antibody illusion with over
99
of signal removal for the six markers
while preserving the tissue morphology
and the epitopes at the same time all
this with a
high level of consistency
so we're now moving to the second part
of the study which is the transfer
of the multiplexing essay on using lab
set
on a different tissue type a cancer
teacher so multiplexing essay
optimized and tonsil can sometimes not
be completely adapted
to other specific tumor sections because
of different marker expression patterns
or sometimes tissue specificities like
different structures
different levels of photoversions etc
the question we ask here is
is this tonsil optimized protocol
applicable to my cancer tissue samples
we approach this with a three-step
transfer strategy
first we applied the tonsil optimized
protocol directly
to our cancer sample then we evaluated
the performance
and defined what needed to be
re-optimized and finally
we modified protocol parameters in order
to reach
the desired performance i'm going to
we're going to go through
um a small case study on non-smoking
lung carcinoma old humor
and teammate sections our objective is
to reach
an acceptable performance on this tissue
in a
minimum number of optimization step
because
our aim is to avoid the re-optimization
from zero
labsat offers the flexibility of
optimization
and some important parameters can be
readjusted
directly from the software interface
like the antenna triple temperature the
incubation
times but also protocols are modular
you can add extra steps like blockings
quenching etc and of course you can
always play with the
standard element of an essay like region
titrations
so um the first phase of the transfer
strategy
we applied the the tonsil optimized
protocol directly
on non-smart cell lung carcinoma samples
ig stainings of the corresponding
tissues are shown
here as references for marker expression
and we could observe that the direct
application of the protocol
on this particular tissue showed lower
intensity levels than expected
for all the markers compared to what we
had on tonsil
which indicates that re-optimization
might be needed
so we applied consecutively two simple
protocol adjustments the first one was
to increase
the antigen retrieval temperature of the
assay
and the second one was to increase opal
540
concentration opal 540 is the terminate
that
termite that we associated with the cd8
and this was enough to rescue the signal
levels and to show appropriate
detections for
all the markers we then apply this
reoptimize six flex
to nsclc tissue microarray
in order to assess the protocol on
various
expression patterns and here the
re-optimized protocol should appropriate
detection
of all the markers on on those
tma cores comparably to the standard ihd
reference
various pattern of expression could be
detected similarly to the iot reference
using this reoptimized protocol
and the total time of the sa remain
remained unchanged
compared to the tonsil optimized
protocol
staying at 4 hours and 12 minutes
so as a conclusion labsat offers the
possibility to run a six flex seven
color sa
in a timely manner with high quality
results
both in terms of signal uniformity strip
off efficiency
and morphology preservation the tonsil
optimized protocol could be transferred
to land cancer tissue for the same assay
duration
and the protocol transfer process was a
simple
two-step adaptation thank you all for
attending this webinar
i encourage you to send all the
questions you might have to the email
address you see below
communication at lunaford.com we'll get
back to you individually
thank you and have a good day